now having the body object from a
collision is good but it lacks specific
information that allows us to react with
our game logic code as such we need some
way to correlate a body to an entity
that created that body now there's a
number of ways to do this we could
create hash tables and lookups and all
this other stuff or we can use one of
the interesting nuances of box2d
specifically physics bodies in box2d
contain a user data property they can
point to any other object in memory or
some subset of data for our purposes
we're going to use that member and
assign it to whatever the owning entity
is for this body that way when a
collision callback occurs each body will
have a pointer to its owning entity
allowing us to do game specific logic as
we need to to get started with this we
need to modify the physics engine add
body code and assign body user data if a
user data variable has been passed in as
part of the calling settings to this
function